joining us back here on the rich eisen
show is one of the top pass rushers
in the national football league from the
world champion
defending world champion tampa bay
buccaneers shaq barrett back here on the
rich eisen show how are you doing chet
i'm doing good i appreciate you uh
having me on uh today
thank you for coming on uh how does that
sound that introduction world champion
sounds amazing i love being a two-time
and then with the bucks because
it's been a struggle for the buck for a
couple years and be able to turn it
around
get a fan something to really support
that's right and so
uh how much better can your team be i
think we uh
reached close to where we could be at
towards the end of the year
without defense and all since we became
uh
closer as a team the camaraderie and the
locker room on the field
like we just kept growing now what
there's a whole offseason together in
the second year for some of the guys and
then
like the third year for the uh being
with the new coaches so it's gonna be uh
still recent balance that we can go and
i think we will achieve it early in the
season
and keep it going throughout the whole
season and um the concept of keeping the
team together
when you guys finished with your boat
parade
um what did you did you think it would
be possible with all the free agents
for this to actually happen i thought
at least a couple of us would have been
gone but like we made it work
uh jason light made it work the front
office made it work
i know ba wanted it to work we wanted it
to work we knew we had some special uh
brewing we wanted to continue it and
keep it going for as long as possible
well i mean how much of a role did
everybody have potentially
in talking to one another during the
process um to to
to keep everybody together i mean was
was there a conversation amongst all
of you from with you and your your
fellow bucks who were up
to say let's let's kind of do it all
together but obviously
you needed to to to get yours for the
lack of a better phrase i mean that's
what this is this game is about is
is winning but also uh taking advantage
of your opportunities monetarily while
you can
so what was that like so we really
didn't have no conversations we
knew that what we had was special as a
unit as a team
so we knew that well i knew if i could
speak personally i knew that i
i didn't want to leave there's an
organization i love the way they do
things here
the locker room we had a lot of great
guys in the locker room it was just a
first-class organization all the way
around and now we added the winning tour
so now was most definitely a first class
organization all the way around
but i think we just all knew that
something special was uh
could take place here and we wanted to
be a part of it and we all was able to
pretty much reach deals that satisfied
us satisfied
uh well not even satisfied made me happy
and i know it made a lot of other people
happy
so we eventually i mean we pretty much
did what was best for us and what was
best for us was
everybody coming back here to be a part
of winning and still being able to
make some money as well and it's got to
be um
quite a feeling as well that everybody's
back
right it's got to be a feeling a great
feeling that that
that you know if the front office told
you hey we we can't go
to this number because we've got to sign
other people and trust us we'll
we'll do our best to do it and then they
did it that's got to be
quite a feeling as you guys get set to
reunite
at the mandatory mini camp next week yes
sir
like yeah like you said it perfectly
like having everyone back together
like man it's just the best feeling like
how we was able to
maneuver all the numbers so that cat hit
would be able to make it work for this
year
so like they did that job in the front
office for sure
we uh did our job uh negotiating making
it work here
i know man i know like everybody here
who was here last year is happy to be
back again
we love our coaches love our teammates
like that like
said it early but like everyone here is
like great people here
they do everything right and just to see
the way he was able to get everything
going and to manipulate the situation to
be able to afford everybody and bring
everybody back it's just perfect and i'm
happy that we get to build uh
another year together to try to i want
to become a dynasty
so that's what uh pretty much motivated
me i'm pretty sure that
motivated a lot of other people too
shaquille barrett right here on the rich
eisen show from the tampa bay
buccaneers now you've said in the first
couple minutes of our conversation here
a couple of times at least that they do
it right here
that they that they're first class and
do it right here with the buccaneers
what do you mean by that what do they do
right so just like having the coaches
that we have we have a lot of coaches
who played
before so they understand like
and don't ask for unreasonable things
and practice they don't want you to
sit here and just just do stuff that
don't have no effect on the game and
i've been
to situations where they coached on
every little thing nitpicked everything
and it's good for some situations but
the situation that we is down here like
it just
we all grown man we know how we need to
handle our business ba is a
a great culture players coach he know
when to uh
push the gas when they push the brake
with us so just
front office they know like how to
communicate everything down to us
they don't like sugarcoat anything you
keep it real what is it that's the only
thing you can actually use for 100
honesty
to the best of my knowledge i'm pretty
sure everybody's been getting it on the
game like
even when it was a tough situation when
a guy was coming out and he was putting
another guy in on certain downs like
the coaches communicated what was going
on how they was going to handle it and
that's all we wanted was just the
honesty and the openness
to so we can know what's going on
instead of saying
like yeah you you gonna be in it we want
you in there and then
as soon as the game come you're not in
there so just like
just just being honest that's pretty
much the
doing things the right way just being
honest and communicating with your
players so while we're being honest here
what point did things click for you last
year
for as a team because we all know that
it wasn't uh
it wasn't a 16-0 season it was catch and
fire
uh after thanksgiving and then not
letting up on the
on the gas the entire way until you
celebrated a championship
because and and and then the first time
you you saw kansas city
that first quarter was a nightmare um
when did things kind of click for you
was there a moment an
ex a play what can you tell me shaquille
barry
so what it started clicking was probably
that kansas city game after
we went out there later egg and pretty
much the first half
we came back in at halftime and just a
coach of bulls just got us together
saying like
minus some big plays he was doing a
pretty good job so we came out changed
the play call and we had like
v8 i mean that'd be a coach both did a
great job with gang planning all the
time so he always put us in the right
position to succeed
so coming in after the halftime i think
that's when stuff started clicking for
us and
we started to realize how good we could
be if we eliminated the big plays and
everybody do that role
on decent and probably yeah i would say
more definitely after the chiefs game
we started uh find out grooves and
start to hit the gas but for me
personally
i don't really think i hit hit the gas
until like the saints playoff game is
when
i was able to find my rhythm and get
going and
like the way i judge my plea on the
field is like the same game is when i
started uh like playing a way that i
wanted to play and
stopped thinking too much and just
started bringing out the inner child in
me like man this opportunity too big to
let
pass me by so make sure i do everything
possible to
help the team get to the super bowl and
win a super bowl because going to the
playoffs it's fun but
nobody want to go to the playoffs and
just lose and start all over next year
so i that was like my main thing i don't
want to start all over next year without
being the champion so i was going to do
and will the team to victory as much as
i could
i don't know if you saw shaquille
barrett the announcement involving uh
tom brady and and phil mickelson against
aaron rodgers and bryson deshambo in a
golf
outing on july 6th and brady tweeting
um at uh bryson de chambeau known for
his
300 and prodigious 350 360
yard drives uh telling him that he he
should learn to lay up because his
partner
we know aaron rodgers isn't going for it
did you see that
tweet from brady yeah that was the
exchanges was funny online i was there i
was getting a nice little kick out of it
i like uh i just like the just the funny
and the joking joking
part of it glad that everybody could
have fun with it and uh
i mean fun at other people's expense
because
i was about to say i don't i don't know
if everyone was having fun with it but
um
i guess that's my way of also walking in
through the side door here were you
surprised that rogers trotted off the
field on that fourth down in the nfc
championship game
yeah i was for sure i was telling the
defense like no
come back they're gonna go for it
they're gonna go for then i look over to
that sideline so that kicker running
that
i'm like oh i appreciate that i really
like i was 100 confident
that our offense was not going to give
them the ball back to give them
opportunity to
come and get any scoring play or
anything going
because i saw earlier in the year before
many situations we've been real
good earlier so i had 100 confidence
that that was the we were still in the
game after they kicked that field goal
i mean look shaquille i mean i know when
you're rookie season you you you came up
and you you saw peyton manning
uh obviously in denver and you're a
two-time super bowl champion
um and then you know geez uh brady now
what what is it like being a teammate uh
of toms
when you say something you know the
offense isn't gonna give the ball back i
mean most of america
pretty much sensed that as well at the
time so
what is that like for you oh it feel
good because you know
tom been in every situation possible he
always going to maintain it's cool
he always going to pretty much make the
best play and
put it in positions for a decision to
succeed and
like that's what he's been doing gaming
game out so
having that veteran leadership out there
on the field off the field
is just amazing his uh like his
personality in the locker room is
cool like i didn't get to interact with
pete and too much because i was younger
i
wanted to stay out the way and try my
spot on the team right
yeah so i'll be interacting with tom a
little bit more and he's a cool guy
funny guy
he talked about my time in denver versus
the peaches and stuff bringing that up
from time to time
and uh it just be fun it's fun to have
him on the team
and i love his his fire that he played
with on the field
and i think that might be the only
difference between peyton and tom like
you could see the fire and tom on the
field and p
he's more lead back on the field but i
uh i love playing with
them for sure and i'm happy i was able
to win with both of them well i guess
maybe one of the reasons why
you didn't see peyton's uh you know uh
anger on the field or
intensity on the field is you weren't a
wide receiver maybe running the wrong
route for him
oh yeah yeah for sure
you were just trying to get him back on
the field so hey uh shaquille thank you
for the time i appreciate it uh best of
luck uh you'll be at the mandatory mini
camp next week with your teammates enjoy
that
um and um and congrats on on you hitting
your
your your multi-year contract you played
your way into it
and um and then to a a ring with tampa
congratulations on that
i appreciate it and i'm definitely
looking forward to getting back with the
guys and start
uh well continued as a progressive
progress we made this past year the
latter half of the year and i appreciate
the
contract that they gave me and i'm just
ready to work and make them know that it
was worth it
thanks for the call shaquille congrats
uh all right we'll do it again soon at
shaquille
with uh just one l barrett on twitter
at moochman6 on instagram hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here